a russian opposition leader who was
poisoned over the summer is speaking out
to 60 minutes correspondent leslie stahl
in his first u.s television interview
since the incident
alexa navalny a rival to russian
president vladimir putin
is recovering in berlin after the
suspected assassination attempt
he was poisoned by a nerve agent called
novichok
navalny pieced together what he thinks
may have happened on that fateful day
in this sunday's 60 minutes they
discover another chalk this nerve agent
uh in my blood in the inside of body on
my body and all this bottle
from the hotel so that's why we
now we know that i was poisoned in the
hotel because i
uh well it's again it's just a pure
speculation because no one knows
what what what happened exactly but i
think that
when i was uh maybe put some clothes
with this um with this poison on me i
touch it with the hand and then
i sip from the bottle so this nerve
agent was
not inside of a bottle but on the bottle
novochok
is a highly toxic nerve agent said to be
ten times more potent than sarin gas
labs in france and sweden corroborated
the finding
there's no doubt it was military-grade
novochuck
it's maybe it's the most toxic
agents invented by the humans so it's
new type of novichok which prove that
unfortunately putin
have a developing new program of this
chemical weapon which is forbidden
the russians have said that they
destroyed all these chemical weapons
that's why actually they deny everything
because
it means that they still have this
navichoke so it means
they're not just violating with keeping
it they
continue to improve it and leslie
stahl joins us now leslie good morning i
noticed
and i noticed in that video of of you in
berlin with navalny that there were
about 15
uh policemen surrounding him i know he
intends navalny intends to go back to
russia which is pretty stunning what's
what's going to be done to
to protect him well we don't know what's
going to
be done to protect him in russia right
now
the germans so concerned that there may
be another attempt on his life
uh that that he walks out of a room a
hotel
wherever he's staying his apartment and
as you say there are
phalanxes of police surrounding him
wherever he goes yeah and and uh it's
pretty amazing he says uh he says he
intends to go back as i mentioned and
that
uh his job uh is is not to be afraid
leslie stahl thank you very much you can
watch leslie's interview with alexia
navalny
on 60 minutes this sunday night at 7 6
central right here on cbs